all right gabby and sam
gaby and sam you guys are from virginia
right
yeah
shenandoah valley and uh i was born in
martinsburg west virginia i grew up in
winchester virginia okay
and uh you you guys are going through
something that is
probably more common than a lot of
people realize uh gabby
you you've been married for how long
almost 12 years
12 years happily married yeah you seem
to be yeah but uh
maybe explain to me what what happened
to you
since you got married right yeah after
when you when you guys married this was
not something you did we got married i
was 20 and i was independent and
i like to
do my favorite hobbies which were riding
horses and i worked a lot and i babysat
and it's just kind of a normal person i
was temperamental and moody and i had a
lot of arguments with people but
i was mostly normal and i didn't have
all these panic attacks i have now it
was very different so
and i got pregnant five years after we
got married about four and a half years
i'm you know trying to get pregnant
planning it and
i thought i had prepared really well i
talked to so many people that had kids
and read stuff and i thought i was just
ready to be a good mother and all this
stuff and i think i am but
nothing could have prepared me for
what happened uh in june 2015.
i got postpartum psychosis
it's a rare mental illness it's not
postpartum anxiety like some people
think it's not postpartum depression
which is most common
and so few women get only about one in a
thousand but the women that get it often
have really bad things happen to them so
without sam helping me and his family i
could have ended up like them it's
fairly common for women like that to
kill themselves
or even their babies
when they're like that's
tell me about the behavior that that
changed
it's such a sudden onset so
you know after after we had our first
our first kid
it was you know it's obviously a very
exciting time for us and we
we'd planned to have kids and
and everything went smooth there was no
problems and
you know it was all good and
and
now you know looking back there was only
a few
slight signs that something was going on
but until you go there until you know
that someone is insane or something you
you have a lot of mechanisms where you
make excuses like oh maybe they were
just you know feeling bad or whatever
but if you don't know where it's leading
you'll just assume that it's all gonna
even out
uh i think like a day or two before
you became like paranoid of the
microwave you thought it was like
leaking radiation or something and it
was kind of an old piece of junk anyways
you know so i was just like yeah get rid
of it i'll get another one a day or two
before the baby came no a day or two
before she cracked okay this was like
three months so for the timeline most
women that have postpartum mental
illness whichever one they have happens
within about six weeks giving birth for
me it was unusual and different and this
confused the hospital too
my postpartum psychosis happened when
the baby was four months old
and then something else happened with
the next baby i'll talk about that um
when he was four months old so a couple
of days before i went to the hospital i
had the illusions about the microwave
yeah and at first i thought she was just
upset about the microwave being broke
and
you know being like oh it's leaking
radiation maybe just being a little too
extreme about it so
i i enjoy
studying science and stuff like that i
know that you know microwaves don't use
radiation they use
they use radio waves or radiation is
different you know
um so we just threw it out as whatever
and i think it was like a day or two
later
and i'll just tell from my from my
viewpoint um
um i woke up it's probably 5 a.m or
something like that and i i just saw her
sitting on the side of the bed
which is
not unusual you know she'd get up to to
help vernon our young our oldest yeah
this was the baby that was right oh i
got his name was vernon when i got to
psychosis yeah and she's just sitting
there for a while and i was like oh is
everything okay and she was like
you know be quiet and i was like i
thought it was something to do with a
baby i was like what's going on
and she starts this whole thing where
she's like they're watching us
you know there's cameras i see there's
cameras we had this little nightlight in
the bathroom she was convinced there's
camera in it
she thought that they were
they were watching us you know and i was
like whoo who and i you know i had
up to this point i had zero experience
with any mental illnesses
there's just none of it in my family and
i have a very large family i'm from a
family of 10 kids and
you know and lots of cousins and stuff
like that and there's
i guess mental illness just really isn't
our thing you know
i just never been around it so i i was
taking all this seriously i was like
what did you see like
did you find something in our house you
know
and and this starts going on and you
know in my mind i'm starting to just
i'm starting to doubt this because i'm
like there's there's no camera in the
night light this isn't i i know what
cameras look like and i've taken apart
plenty of things and
so this goes on and we get up in the
morning and
you know it's probably 7 a.m and she's
just going on with all these just
paranoid delusions but at this point i
didn't think it was delusions i thought
maybe she was mistaken or something
freaked her out and she was scared and
maybe just blowing things out of
proportion or
it was
it was really hard to grasp so
eventually
i didn't want to handle this on my own
especially with a little kid so we went
over to my parents house
and
because she was part of these delusions
she was convinced my dad was like
some drug dealer kingpin and i was
involved in it it was like a family
thing and
and maybe and she thought that
because he knew because she knew about
it that now now she's on a hit list to
get killed or something or you know she
knows too much or something and i this
was like what
would suddenly make you believe this so
we go to my parents house and on the way
over
she's just freaking out like just just
oh i think they're all going to be dead
when we get there they're already dead
and and like we would pass a car or
something and it would be like did you
see that person they're following us or
you know just everything just
the amount of of information and
delusions coming in was
is just astonishing the amount of stuff
your mind was able to just put together
and make up and so we get there and
obviously my parents aren't dead
and we get talking about this and i
think you got into like this intense
conversation with my dad like trying to
call him out as a
the kingpin and he was like cell phone
out of his hand looked through all his
text yeah to make sure he wasn't like
texting i've never done anything like
that before it was nothing like me
yeah so at this point we're just
because we have no experience with this
at all we're just what is going on here
and i think what what finally made us
decide to take you to the hospital like
hours later later late morning early
afternoon
was uh
you started having this really bad onset
of amnesia like you would just
we would talk something through
and and confirm that okay this didn't
happen because i was there and you were
there and you saw it and you know i
wasn't out selling drugs or whatever
and and then like five minutes later you
wouldn't remember
any of that like you would just
all of that information went right out
the other ear like a stroke victim yeah
and so we were like she having a stroke
or something like she can't remember
anything
like this is bad so we need to go to the
hospital so we we had to like
talk her into going to the hospital
because she at this point she doesn't
think that anything's wrong with her
everything's wrong with us
so we're like oh we'll just go down and
we'll just talk to some people and
that's that's what i thought it was
gonna be we're just gonna talk to some
people you know
get a head scan or something make sure
you're not gonna die on us
so we get down there and and the
emergency room is just
i don't know yeah you've been to the
emergency room it's we wait for hours
they're not you know we're there like we
need to talk to somebody about this and
they're not taking us seriously at all
they're like okay whatever sit over
there i think like two three hours later
they finally get us a room
they send in a bunch of social workers
and they're like what's going on and
we're like trying to describe this and
they
they're behaving like they just never
heard of any of this before
and i was like they were definitely
googling it on their phones yeah yeah
they were they were trying to look this
up the the emergency room doctor i
remember was i think calling a red cell
phone and he was kind of a little angry
just yelling frustrated saying what's
wrong with you i have people dying i
need to figure out what's wrong with you
and that was the first time that i was
slightly back in reality because i was
trying for a moment to help him figure
out what was wrong with me and then i
just slipped back into the psychosis
yeah you seemed like when we got to the
house it was very confused why you were
there i think you mentioned later how
you thought
on the way down you thought that we were
going to see like your grandma my mom
your mom my mom's never been she hasn't
been in the hospital or sick but i
thought that maybe she was sick dying in
the hospital because i couldn't think of
any other reason why we would be going
to the hospital
um
so when i got the psychosis
here's how to describe it to someone
who's never had psychosis i got a flight
of ideas i wasn't in a manic episode yet
it was just a sudden very sudden
psychosis i was sitting in a rocking
chair i had gotten up with the baby it
was real early in the morning the
rocking chair from the thrift store i
can remember everything it looked like
and stuff
suddenly it's like picture these
thoughts coming they're not like
thoughts that come from your mind
they're just like going through the air
like scrolling across the screen like on
a news show or something
lots of thoughts at once and then it's
like your brain just grabs the wrong
ones so
i started thinking about our landlord
for some reason just like these
obsessive thoughts like
our landlord gets a lot of money each
month i thought my brain was wide awake
and racing sort of but not really manic
yet it's like arnold gets a lot of money
wondering where he gets that money from
oh wait and then i just knew he gets
that money because my husband's a drug
dealer oh wait so i grabbed that thought
no he's a drug dealer and they're all
drug dealers and that's why he has
crooked teeth because his parents all
smoke meth or whatever you do with meth
and
they're all meth dealers and they're
going to kill me later and once i knew
that your mothering instincts the
hormones and stuff that you have make
you want to protect the baby now those
instincts can go terribly wrong
and in some in some percentage of cases
where mothers do unfortunately commit
infanticide they actually think they're
saving their baby from something now to
be clear i never had infanticide
thoughts or urges or any murderous urges
towards anyone but some women do and i
just think it's important to clarify
that because people don't understand
it's very very cases where women have
killed their own children
andrea yates for example when she killed
her children she had postpartum
psychosis she thought she was saving
them from hell and if she didn't kill
them they would go to hell
so they're not doing it to hurt people
but yes it's still terrible it's just
important i think because i've had
postpartum psychosis now to explain that
there's been
very few women trying to advocate for
women like me trying to help them and i
want to be one of them and explain
things clearly so anyway um and you know
when you get postpartum psychosis it's
an emergency no matter what you need to
get medical treatment pretty much
probably drugs or something like that
you can't yeah you can't handle it at
home right
well you at least need to have somebody
watching you making sure you don't just
run away with these delusions yeah it's
very dangerous
so so um i did not have
to killing anyone myself or anyone but i
had the delusions that i had to get out
i had to take the baby away from him
because he's a drug dealer and his
family was
um then i started to get the delusions
about the the cameras
in the bathroom the nightlight was a
camera there's cameras everywhere in the
room
um one of our neighbors we met um
since we'd only lived there a few years
he i thought since he was kind of a big
sort of hairy man i thought he was a
bear like an actual bear i thought that
he was under the house for some reason
like a bear just crawling around
um
and then we went so we went to his
parents house that was
weird and scary so when i got there he
was saying i thought they were dead yeah
i thought they were dead
and when i got there i knew they were
dead like i knew they were dead
so and his sister was there and i i
touched her i touched his mom's face too
but i knew she was dead it doesn't
matter that i could feel her she was
dead i knew that these delusions are
like just like you know that that wall
is red and that chair looks like a
um a throne you just know you don't have
to explain it's just you suddenly know
this delusion
so it's very hard to be unconvinced of
that
so i knew that we were all dead we were
in heaven or something maybe narnia his
sister
uh looked like a projection like like a
movie slide or something
um just fake just everything about her
seemed fake
um your brain just decided she was fake
common sense
won't no the more you try to the more we
tried to convince her of stuff just the
more elaborate the conspiracy got it was
like well if that's not true then
there's just this other layer of
elaborate conspiracy
about how you know we're tricking her to
think it's this or that and
there's no convincing it like but we we
tried i mean because we didn't
we didn't know anything that's to be
terribly difficult on a marriage
yeah i mean i mean long term long term
i've learned a lot of ways to there's
lots of things you can do
to cope with that but um
continuing the story so we after we get
to the hospital
and they're they're they're not sure
what's going on um they're like we think
she should stay here overnight
um because they just kept asking her are
you suicidal do you want to kill
yourself like that was just their
question i guess they asked her that
everybody
yeah everybody
everybody that comes in the room is like
you want to kill yourself you know
thoughts of harming yourself right and
it's like no no nobody wants to kill
anybody here like
i don't know why they keep bringing this
up but it's like their liability thing i
guess to make sure that you say that you
don't want to kill yourself whether it's
true or not
so
they're like we think she should stay
overnight and and i keep pressing why
like what do you think what do you think
is wrong with her like what do you think
this is what can we do we want to talk
to maybe a counselor a psychiatrist
and um
they they were like down in the er
they said
we don't really know what's wrong with
her you can't talk to psychiatrists you
know basically the only way to get to a
psychiatrist if you don't have one
already is you have to be admitted and
they're gonna they're gonna send you to
the sixth floor so
the fifth floor the fifth floor sorry um
so this hospital has a whole
mental ward on top floor you know it's
it's one of the they told me was there's
like one of the top 10 hospitals on the
east coast it cost like
nine 10 billion dollars it's crazy
yeah that's what they were telling me
and so i i was like wow we're in really
good hands you know they really got this
down they got an entire floor dedicated
to this you know we're we're good
but i was like i don't you know why does
she need to get admitted to the hospital
you know what he's explaining what's
going on it's not like oh your legs
broken and your your bone's sticking out
so we need to fix that it was more like
we don't know what's wrong with her we
think she should stay here because we
don't know what's wrong with her and i
was like what
i just wanted to talk to i wanted to
talk tomorrow i was just getting a lot
of social workers and a lot of nurses
and i wasn't really getting any
any psychiatrists or counselors or heads
of departments of anything
so i was a little like i don't know i
don't know i was just in indecision
and uh before we know it
uh this you know a couple hours later
this this hospital official walks in and
he's like she's staying here
we already pulled a temporary detention
order on her 50 150 right they get a
judge on the phone they just they just
they take your rights away and you that
you're now their prisoner basically they
won't let you leave they get security in
there
and they're like she has to stay here
and you know at this point she's holding
our kid and they're like kid can't stay
here so they just yank the kid away
that's when i started screaming right it
just be it it immediately escalates to
this
just crazy trauma thing because they're
like taking her baby away
they're hauling her off like she's a
criminal or something
and and we can't do anything it's like
it's it's like illegal for us to even
try to stop this because it took me
about two days before i could say
anything to anyone who came into my room
except
crying where's my vernon where's my baby
and then i found out later that in the
uk where they're actually sensible they
have mother baby maternal mental health
wards so you can visit your baby with
guidance and you know
but it helped a lot
and throughout this experience which
which really it was important to me and
i saw how this all works
they're getting all of their opinions
and information from her they will not
take my experience of this
they won't even listen to me they they
don't want to listen to me because i'm
not the patient i'm just i'm just the
spouse i'm just the
person living in the same house you know
and i'm like
this is
this was starting to blow me away i was
like because
i brought her here because i was
concerned for health she doesn't think
anything's wrong but it's obvious
something's wrong i was worried about
paying the bill i was like you're not
gonna get my credit card my subscription
number i'm not gonna pay a bill i don't
need to be here because at this point
you have you think there's nothing wrong
me and my parents are there and we're
like there's something wrong
and and instead of coming to us and
being like what do you think is wrong
they go directly to her and be like
what's wrong with and you're like
there's nothing wrong
and it just becomes this confusing thing
where they'll only get information from
the patient they won't listen to any of
the family members
and and the information she's giving
them is just totally wrong like she's
just like there's nothing wrong i'm
sleeping great i don't know what you're
talking about you know she has no idea
why we're at the hospital because you
think we're there to see your mom
and part of the problem when your manic
grandiose or psychotic which kind of all
go together is you think that you're
okay and you're the one who's really
really right and really in the know
everyone else is wrong which is a really
dangerous way to think when you're like
that because
no one can stop you and no one can
convince you otherwise no one can get
into that yeah
i'm sure there's different degrees of
this
yes there's many different degrees all
depending on how unhinged you are
so a milder mania could just be maybe
sleeping five or six hours a night
instead of
eight or ten
being a little more excited a little
more happy a little more spontaneous not
very harmful at all at all but maybe a
little grandiose a little self-important
a little bit less judgment maybe a
little bit not bad for your own good
yeah say stuff that you don't mean like
doesn't require hospitalizations if
you're on meds it usually takes care of
it then there's mania which is a more
serious situation
less sleep more granules thinking more
delusions
dangerous reckless behavior and then you
go to psychosis which usually goes with
mania so
where it's just you know is this related
to like bipolar yes yeah so bipolar one
yeah so we they lock her up they're like
she's gonna be here for like two weeks
but they don't know they're not gonna
they're not gonna tell me anything
um the psychiatrist they had there
he was
probably pretty decent at his job he but
he deals with such they have one one
head psychiatrist is an indian guy i
think yeah
and the volume of crazy people he deals
with is just
he's only got time to spend like 10
minutes per patient per day so he'll
just look at you and be like i don't
know let's try this then he moves on to
the next person
um
so they put you on they put you on
seroquel they gave me circle but they
gave me shots of of things first
they gave me shots of hal doll
when i
i when the nurse was going to lock me up
the
i thought that they were locking me up
forever i didn't know anything nobody
explained anything and my instinct was
just to get out so i put my arms my
hands around her neck when i did that
she called a whistle and someone came up
and shot me with how doll they took my
pants off and guys are looking at me and
stuff and that was very humiliating
there was so much shame long after this
with me having to deal with long time
before i could go in public without
being ashamed
anyway same about making a fool of
yourself or yeah and and thinking that
people would think i'm a bad person and
i can't be in public and people had seen
me so you came to your senses
and did you realize what you had done
yes i did
later with her neck no just in general
this whole experience yes i did later
yeah it took a long time really for you
to
i think after you
after we got you out of the hospital
which was
it becomes a whole legal thing like as
soon as they
pull a tdo on you
they get a judge involved they they they
just they take your rights away they
literally take your rights away you're
you're you're like a grade below a felon
you can't you can't own firearms or
transport them and you become
a low-grade criminal
and but they don't tell you much about
this so they
the only person who filled us in about
this stuff
was our our
lawyer they gave to us they just yeah
they appoint you an attorney they
appoint you an attorney
and and you have a hearing in the
hospital before they let go yeah that
was that was just a shocking thing
because it's like i thought we were
going to the hospital to get a counselor
and now we got judges and lawyers and
it's like now i'm like in a courtroom
and i don't i have no idea why this is
all happening like i had no idea that if
you're
unhinged a little bit suddenly suddenly
you get judges and lawyers involved and
so
they do a hearing
like the next morning judge comes in
i try to explain the situation to him
he doesn't really care the judge doesn't
care because he's just there to verify
that the hospital didn't wrongly take
her off the street because of the the
you know self-serving interest of all
this gets a little messy where you know
if the hospital wants more business what
keeps them from just taking people off
the street is saying you're crazy
so a judge has to review it and he was
like ah it sounds like she was on him
she's staying here i was like what this
you know this was just balls my mind was
swimming i had no idea
um so she stayed there for
about a week or so
about a week yeah
and they you know they finally released
her i pretended to be better to be well
so they would let me go earlier
unfortunately a lot of people do that
yeah it's really hard to open up to them
and try to get real help because they
just don't seem to care
so
um
after i got discharged with that i got
diagnosed with bipolar one and
i started taking seroquel and and
they gave me a prescription for it but i
stopped taking it really soon after i
got out and i went back to being pretty
crazy but not quite that bad
then
i wasn't taking any medication at all
and i was just out of the hospital and
then i had my my next child very soon
after and after i had him i didn't get
psychosis again but i got postpartum
panic attacks and anxiety really really
bad and then i got agoraphobia which
means i was afraid of open spaces
leaving my home and getting panic
attacks
outside of my home
that lasted from 2017 till 2021 so about
four years and i didn't leave my house
almost at all for four years so i just
stayed home sam did all the shopping
brought stuff to me i didn't take the
kids out anywhere my parents or friends
would take them out
i just didn't leave and i didn't
throughout all this throughout all this
you know like when you got out of the
hospital we were like they were like you
need to get a psychiatrist and we're
like where where how do we do that and
they're like they sent us to the
community services board which is
basically just a county run you know
thing
and they they weren't taking us
seriously at all like they were just
like as soon as they saw that we had a
vehicle and we owned a house you know we
have a house and all this stuff they
were like why are you even here and it's
like uh we need a psychiatrist like why
yeah because they're just used to
dealing with they didn't feel bad it's
drug and abuse situations and
they didn't take it serious at all that
just didn't work at all what i ended up
doing to help myself was i started a
youtube channel when i was not leaving
the house
the channel helped me feel like i had a
community and i told my story and that
helped me a lot and i healed a lot but i
still wasn't leaving the house and then
as far as things that keep me sane i
don't really take medications much the
only medication i take is hydroxyzine
which is like basically benadryl on
steroids very light medication but it's
very effective for me because i'm
sensitive and i take nutritional
supplements that helped me a lot i found
out my hormones were low i had to take
progesterone hormone to balance that out
b vitamins vitamin c magnesium zinc
lots of things
and lithium orotate which is not
prescription lithium it's its own kind
it's special it's lithium or tank you
get it over the counter i can
anyway um those things you kind of
became your own doctor yes i became my
own doctor i did tons of research online
i looked at other people's situations
and researched nutrition and i found out
that lack of b vitamins which can get
depleted when you're nursing a baby
causes psychosis
so i started taking b vitamins and i've
never had full psychosis since
it helped me a lot and people with
brains that have susceptibility to these
problems because i have genetic
susceptibility
have a hard time assimilating b vitamins
unless they're in a methylated form so i
got a methylated b vitamin and it just
goes straight to helping
my brain it's very good
very helpful that's great i had just
mostly self-directed uh help and and i
think i'm on a huge path of recovery
because so i i didn't leave the house
for four years all i could do was walk
outside maybe a fourth of a mile down
the road on a good day
and
i just rode in the car six to six and a
half hours
it's a huge triumph for me like you're
here yeah yeah i'm just so proud of
myself
it's wonderful you can get some recovery
i mean this must be terribly hard on a
marriage it was hard yeah i
that got bad it's time tell me tell me
tell me the thoughts you were having
while this is though um
so
right and this is this is really what it
boils down to is
the
the entire mental health
infrastructure we have
is entirely based off of
information coming from the patient to
the psychiatrist
and that gets recorded on you know
statistics and data and stuff like that
and they use that to develop different
treatments or drugs or whatever
um but they're
they don't
they're not interested
in the viewpoints of the family members
and why that's important
is because the person they're getting
the information from is broken their
mind is not behaving
well at all
they'll just totally forget things
totally
kind of like how you got out of the
hospital the first time
you fake your way out you're like oh i'm
fine you don't you don't start any
fights you're like oh yeah i'm gonna
take the medicine
you just fake your way out and like as
soon as you got out the doors you're
like there's no way i'm taking that
medicine
and and like you had this totally
different attitude and
that that doctor-patient relationship is
is just
it's not effective it's not effective
and i realize everybody doesn't have
family members that are close by to
sort of help them through this but
you know uh by the time you got
agoraphobic and you didn't want to leave
the house you know we had already gone
through
many psychiatrists you're calling them
oh yeah so one psychiatrist that i tried
told me that i was the worst case of
rapid cycling bipolar one he'd ever seen
and to just take a hike he wasn't even
gonna treat he wasn't gonna treat you
and then there would be other ones and
so he'd be like all right let's tone it
down let's try to get into their
practice you know maybe things aren't as
bad as they are so we tone it down but
then as soon as they talk to you and
they they kind of map it out what's
going on they're just like i don't think
you're right for our practice and they
just back out immediately the ironic
thing is i don't even see a psychiatrist
i get my meds from a family doctor i
don't require a psychiatrist care
because i care for myself with my
self-directed treatments supplements so
today
you're much better yes much better yeah
it's taken it's taken many many years
once we sort of got the picture that
psychiatrists we're not going to they're
not going to help us and even if they
did because then you know she started
getting in the whole youtube community
of watching people's videos and seeing
how these people treat this stuff
there'll be people on just piles of
medications
and it barely helps it doesn't help
they're still they're still completely
you know
cut loose there's still people that
don't can't leave the house from panic
attacks that are taking xanax it doesn't
help enough
and so you know there was just a lot of
drug because a psychiatrist the first
thing they're going to want to do is
just put you on this drug for six weeks
if it doesn't work or does they get you
off the drug put you on another one they
just cycle through this and they can
cycle through 10 15 drugs to figure out
what works for you
and that all of that can just
just rip your body apart i've tried
these drugs have terrible side effects
and it can be really hard to come off
some of these
i was open-minded to trying a few that i
didn't strictly want to and i did try
them it didn't work out good but at
least i tried them right it came to the
point where because of how i was raised
i was very resistant to using any quote
modern medicine i had to get
undone a little bit you know what i mean
because you can't always manage 100
without pharmaceuticals depending on how
bad it is so now i'm like yeah one
pharmaceutical is fine the rest is
natural and then you found this song on
the internet
most of your research yes
we had to source it from uh so my mom
helped me find the lithium orotate so
she was a big part of helping with that
right but uh it sounds like it's a lot
of nutritional supplements yes i take
like 20 30 supplements every day
they really helped me a lot
yeah and how we came to that is is once
we decided that you know drugs and
psychiatry wasn't going to work
we got we got a hold of this naturopath
guy i guess he tries to treat people
through all his natural stuff a doc a
natural doctor yeah natural doctor and
and he was the only one who was willing
to actually test for stuff so he would
take hormone panels and he would test
you know test your thyroid and the brain
chemicals like adrenal chemicals things
and he was able to figure out through
that that that she had a very
low progesterone level and i had all the
they're called excitatory transmitters
neurotransmitters that make you have
panic attacks i have tons of those and
very few inhibitory ones yeah but now i
can tell just how by the way i am having
tested and yours my inhibitory
neurotransmitters are much higher
okay naturally what was the most
difficult part for you sam
probably the most difficult part is
once we
because because she only ever went into
really bad psychosis every time she has
a kid right after
and that lasts for a while and we sort
of you know get things more calmed down
but then she'll she settled in
to just bipolar one rapid cycling which
was just two weeks on two weeks off
so there would be two weeks where she's
euthymic which is
is is the terminology for just being
sort of normal
you're not you're not super depressed or
you're not like
racing thoughts
um
and it
it the back and forth was probably the
hardest thing so
when a person's manic i've learned over
the years
you kind of have to treat them like a
child you can't believe what they say
they'll say the most ridiculous things
they'll be like oh i'm super excited to
do this and be all on fire for something
and and throughout the years i've
learned that
it's just it's just a symptom of the
mania they got all these ideas and
they're they're they're gonna pursue
them for five minutes
and and then and then quit it and go on
to something else but i think most
husbands would probably have bailed
right and it was incredibly hard so i
developed this i developed this this
sort of
emotional
protection for myself if
if i start getting early
early detection on a manic episode
coming up
i will just i will just emotionally shut
down i will close the hatch
and i the way i treat her is she's just
my third child you you know they'll just
say a lot of stuff
but i i just really have to box her in
and make sure she doesn't hurt herself
no i don't mean like closer in the house
or anything like that but just like
you know oh i'm gonna i'm gonna go
across the country and do this and i'm
like ah let's wait a few weeks but we're
not gonna do it right now you know just
just just uh put that on on the shelf
for a while any any crazy idea she has i
can't
i can't just be like no cause then
because then she'll dig her heels in and
just and and then just then it'll really
rip our marriage apart because i'm
saying no and i'm oppressing her and
then it becomes a thing
does it take a lot of mental energy to
know how to treat me yes it's it's like
walking on eggshells because
you gotta know
you gotta know how to
how to restrain a person from doing dumb
stuff without making them feel like
you're restraining them
so it's just like oh maybe that's a
great idea let's think about it in a
month or something you know because i
know when she comes down and she's more
normal she's gonna look at all those
ideas she wrote down and be like oh
that's completely ridiculous
um so it's it's and it's really hard i
mean i went to i went to a therapist one
time because it was just
there's there's been a few episodes
she's had that last six eight weeks i'm
just non-stop every day
the talking you know just talking all
day long and it's not like i don't like
talking but
it becomes and i've seen this in a lot
of people i work with now
it becomes a monologue
and they don't care if you're listening
so she'll start talking about something
and the kids might be getting in trouble
and i could walk out of the room and
help the kids and she'll just keep
talking keep talking and then i come
back and she's still talking
and and i started to learn that
this is this is just this thing where
all these ideas are going through your
head and you're getting them out and
you're talking about them
you don't even hardly take them
seriously but you just feel this need to
just keep going and talking talking and
talking
and it becomes this monologue where they
don't really care if you're listening
they just want they just i don't know
like the internal thinking process
becomes an external just oh this idea
comes i'm going to talk about it do you
think sometimes it's like you spend only
half your time with your real wife i
think this when it yeah when it was
really bad
i was keeping charts and stuff like that
to see where you would go
with your moods and stuff and it was
worse it was like about two-thirds of
the time you're manic and about one
third time you weren't manic and i think
the hardest part for me was
once you were coming down there was very
clear symptoms you're coming down
suddenly
suddenly you would pass out on the couch
at 8 pm and be like i'm so tired and
just like sleep all night i'd be like
she's probably coming down the energy is
going way lower
another thing i notice when you're very
manic is your your sense of humor just
leaves yeah like i'll i'll crack a joke
and you'll be like you look at me like
what are you what are you saying
yeah and i'm like uh okay and i don't
know if i'm a hilarious guy or not but i
know for a fact that if you weren't
manic you would probably think that's
funny you know we've lived together for
over a decade i know what makes you
laugh and what doesn't
so uh
you know i could see the obvious signs
of her coming down out of an episode and
a really hard part for me is opening
back up
and and learning to trust again because
when a person's man you can't trust them
you can't you just can't
and when we lie when we're meeting a lot
well you just you have these the ego
thing is a big thing your ego just
blows up to just unreal proportions
where you're like
you'll be like oh i'm going to clean the
whole house today we're going to have
dinner ready and we're going to go to
the park and i'm like that sounds great
but you know from many years of this
i'll come home after work and none of
that got done like you didn't do
anything and i'm like did the kids even
get taken care of like this this is
really concerning for me it looks like
you haven't done anything all day long
so that's a product of bipolar or manic
it's
the mania is a part of bipolar and the
mania makes it so she's got all this
energy and ideas is that because i have
my people like what you just described
yes bipolar for me is mostly manic
not much depression yeah not too much
depression it's just very manic and the
manic comes with all this energy and all
these creative ideas all this
all these promises all these promises
but but she has no focus she cannot
focus on anything the add it's terrible
we're like
how i consider it attention deficit
disorder she cannot pay attention to one
thing
for more than like 10 minutes it becomes
i don't know all these other ideas flood
in and suddenly i'll notice like when
you're manic you have like 10 projects
going like oh i'm going to do this and
i'm going to build this puzzle here and
me and the kids are going to do a
project and all the stuff and nothing
ever gets done like it's just too many
things going on so gabby now that you're
in your right mind yes i am do you do
you look at sam and do you has it made
you guys closer yes did he that he wrote
this out
yes
i think it has in an incredible way i
think we have a lot of trust but our
relationship can be at times because she
still does get manic it's just a lot
less the rapid cycling seems to have
gone away yeah so it's more just like
just the fact that you stuck this out
wrote it out yeah i mean i i i don't
know
yeah i didn't know if it was ever going
to end it seemed like it was never going
to end what about the fights um which i
think you should mention we fought
physically a few times mostly when i was
half out of my mind like one time i
tried to beat him up at his parents one
time she she said she was gonna kill me
because we went to my parents house i i
sweet i spent a lot of time on my
parents house right after i cold turkey
quit my psychotic antipsychotic meds
yeah i tried to spend a lot of time at
my parents house to help me with the
kids and and stuff because she was just
out of it
and there we went there one time and i i
can't even remember what was going on i
was trying to get your paycheck because
you were supposed to get paid for your
dad yeah at that point i was working for
my dad and she was like you you got to
get your paycheck he had i'd worked for
him for 10 years and i didn't really
ever have a problem getting a paycheck
but
um would they keep it concise
i just started beating him up right and
so i was like why she wouldn't come out
of the car like she was just mad it
wouldn't come out of the car and i was
like
you know what's going on and i was like
if you're just gonna be like this you
know that's fine but i'm i'm not going
to spend time out here arguing with you
i'm just going to go in the house and
then she just
and and i think i reached in the truck
the truck and i pulled the keys out
because i i was unsure what you were
going to do and i was afraid of you
driving off my truck and i wouldn't have
a ride so
i just pulled the keys out i was like
you can sit out here if you want
and that just like triggered this rage
she like
threw the threw open the door was like
i'm gonna kill you and just like came
after me
and i mean
i regret it or not i mean i just clocked
you on the side
put you to the ground because i mean you
had this rage in your eyes i don't
remember you hitting me i believed you
were going to try to really hurt me like
trying to kill him so i was like well
i'm not going to fight you i'm just
going to get you down so i just
put you on the ground and i just held
you down and i was like you know you
gotta stop this
i remember screaming at you saying
they're gonna put you back in the
hospital like do you keep this up
they're gonna send you back i won't have
control over this
you're gonna get the law involved and
you know the system is hard brothers was
there and he started to talk to me and
he he had a very special way of talking
and i started listening it was weird it
was more effective than anyone had
talked to me in the hospital who's this
my mother brother
it seemed like he knew how to talk to a
crazy person he had some experience with
that i would just remember he totally
drew me out of that rage and got my mind
working on a problem sort of
it was just so
interesting with no training or any
degrees in medicine he was better at
talking to me than anybody had been in
the hospital
yeah wow
what do you guys say is the most
important lesson you've learned from all
of this
i've learned not to believe uh
not to trust
their respective establishments and to
always be your own advocate and do your
own research
i think the most important thing i've
learned
you always hear in the movies they say
you know the definition of insanity is
doing the same thing over and over again
expecting different results i think
that's completely ridiculous i think
i think everybody does a lot of things
over and over again and they do get
different results eventually
and that's not how psychiatrists define
it they what they're looking for
when they talk to somebody is uh
is linear thought
so they want to see you be able to stack
ideas like you get an idea in your head
and you develop that out to its end and
you stack another idea on top of that
like i'm hungry how about we go get
something to eat oh let's get in the car
and go something and it's across town
and you know you're stacking ideas to to
form an entire action
a person that's struggling
with
mental illness stuff
they can't stack those ideas they'll
stack one stack two get distracted
they'll lose thought track and that's
what they're looking for it's kind of
interesting to say stack ideas because
toddlers at a certain stage of
development um learn how to
follow a two or three step task instead
of just one step and it's like you go
back to less than a toddler stage yeah
what it takes for you to lose that
ability
is a lot less than you think oh yeah if
you have sleep deprivation if you get on
certain drugs
if you
if you get nutritional deficiency
deficiencies if you get you know
blackouts you can bring up pregnancy and
nursing a baby absolutely we are we are
all
this close to losing it um
high high mental capabilities
are really a fine line from just losing
it which is why good nutrition is
probably
right
and the more i got thinking about it
the more i was like you know what we all
have crazy ideas
we have crazy stuff coming to our heads
all the time but we just have the
ability to filter them out you'll just
be like ah that's not that's never gonna
work
you know uh people that
you know uh
somebody you know spits on you or
insults them your brain for a split
second may have like oh i should hit
that guy but you know different people
have different abilities just filter
that out like oh well you know maybe
that's not a good idea i don't want to
fight this guy or whatever
um
which really tells me that we're all a
lot closer to losing it than you think
you've got to take care of your mind you
got to sleep you got to drink a lot of
water
you can't be abusing it with drugs and
stuff like that
insanity is
is the worst thing to happen to somebody
if you've lost the ability to control
your mind
nobody can help you
you know i i think
i think uh
you know i don't wanna
i don't want to act like i'm i'm real
haughty about this but i think you got
very fortunate
being i'm i kind of
the personality i have is i work on a
lot of lost cause stuff you know you
know the vehicles i buy to fix and stuff
like that i always try to help a lost
cause
and i and i sort of adapted that
behavior towards you because i thought i
could really fix you yeah even when we
were just getting to know each other
because i was from a family background
poverty and some neglect and some abuse
he was wanting to help he saw potential
he went i thought i could just if i
could get you out of there and get you
in a normal environment where we just
have a house and
you know we have jobs and you know
boring life maybe i could make you a
little better i
like cinderella right in in
retrospection
i i i could see
i could see some things going on with
her when i was dating her i just
i didn't think anything of it you like
to fix broken birds
i i i you know now that i think about it
i guess i do i just i didn't think of
myself as a person that fixed things but
uh i guess i am stubborn i don't like to
give up i i think that there's a there's
a there's a way if you work on it long
enough um
there was one time back when we were
dating that
we're having a fight over something and
you got very upset and and you just
walked out in traffic and i was like
you know and these cars stopped and
everything like that and i was like wow
she's really upset but that was really
uh
that was a red flag that you were
your mind was
cut loose enough where you would
to prove a point really risk your life
to to to get my attention
you may put yourself in harm's way in a
very real way and i just thought you
were very upset i
didn't come from a family with any of
that sort of stuff
and then um
you know after the fact now that we
because you were i think you were the
first person in your family that really
just broke in a really bad way
and so it got us all talking about this
and then when we start talking about
this all these stories started coming
out
about her family members
and stuff and it was like wow they they
all suffer greatly from stuff though
um
your family yes like her dad he's and
and he and he'll he'll just sort of
laugh about it because he's a very
happy-go-lucky guy he's had over 300
jobs he cannot stay in one spot
and he's been he's been bankrupt a time
or two and he's just a lot of poverty
like i remember growing up we always
thought
but he does not
it took me a long time to figure out
that dads usually
know who the boyfriend the name of their
daughter's boyfriend is and remember
their children's middle names their
birthdays like it's just he's so
detached he's loving and i love him so
much but he's so detached he's like not
he's like an android almost in some ways
just not personal
yeah so he's strong every time i call
him usually he's just like i gotta go in
like 15 minutes you know you know it's
just he's very detached your brother
her older brother's got
some sort of autism going on he's pretty
messed up but my parents never saw any
help for him
yeah they
i think they had just been living
around this sort of stuff and they came
from maybe families that had that stuff
you grew up in a rural part of west
virginia uh winchester virginia i was
born in west virginia but i moved to
winchester and we live in winchester
virginia
kind of rural we were homeschooled and
really sheltered very religious so kind
of a religious
oversaturation and not enough outside
influence
so the brother should have gotten
professional help then turns out my
other two siblings a brother and a
sister also have some form of bipolar
sister's been locked up she's manic she
won't treat it she doesn't think it's a
problem and my brother has issues but
he's he's doing pretty well he does and
how
sam how good would you say gabby's
mental health is now today uh
i'd say it's
i mean like a thousand times better than
it was when this all started
uh it's not i don't think her mental
health is as good as it was when we
first got married because once that once
that kind of trauma happens you can't go
back you have to build something
new um it's gotten to the point where
you know it's it's a bit of a it's a bit
of a dance when if she goes manic a
couple times a year
i have to just put myself through okay
just
you gotta ignore everything she says
just keep it managed for a few weeks
until you know she ups her medication a
little bit you know and lithium mostly
ups the lithium a bit
and rides it out because you can't
that's that's another thing that uh
psychiatry won't tell you once a manic
episode starts you cannot stop it it is
going to go through its course you can
mask it you can take a lot of drugs
uh you know
a hundred and hundred and so years ago
in america they they just had physical
restraints for crazy people they put
them in these you know hospitals they
make horror stories about
um
they have physical restraints for these
people nowadays they don't do that but
they kind of do it's it's a chemical
restraint they put they put drugs in
your body
to restrain you you are still going
through this episode you are still cut
loose
but you can't do anything about it
because your energy is so low you're so
drugged you can't do anything about it
it's a chemical restraint
right you're sedated so once an episode
starts you gotta ride it out you gotta
get it to the point where it's you're
not doing anything to get in trouble
you're not doing anything that's
permanent
you know there's been times you've had
ideas of getting tattoos all over your
body and stuff like that and i'm just
like that's fine but after you come down
because i don't want you doing something
permanent
and then super regretting it later
um i know you know we
me too i like the way your hair is short
now but uh i remember the first time you
did that because you used to have long
hair you were manic and you were like i
want to cut my hair off and you just
chopped it like really short and and it
was just something you regretted a lot
afterwards you're like that i mean
that's like 10 years
of hair growth and it's gone like you
just
and so yeah you just had to adapt your
styles to deal with it and you've kind
of grown to like it a little bit but
that that
you can do a lot of things that you
regret
i say things i regret it's one of the
worst things for me
so many things if a person if you don't
have a person to keep you on the rails
and to sort of box you in a little i
mean that that might sound like i'm
holding you back in life but
we've seen what happened to your sister
she
she sort of lost it ended up getting
locked out she's got a boyfriend but
he doesn't really understand what i
don't think he understands what's going
on and so people do
it's not common he's an expert on this
now which is good
it's a hard road to become an expert
yeah
all right gabby and sam thank you so
much for this very interesting talk yeah
thank you hope it helps a lot of people
i hope to help somebody too
thank you very much
you